THE HEAD BASKETBALL COACH OF
THOSE OREGON STATE BEAVERS
FELLOW MONTANAN.
MR. WAYNE TINKLE WAYNE. HOW
ARE YOU DOING COACH, I'LL
DOING GREAT REALLY GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU. BUT HEY, WE PLAY
LOYOLA CHICAGO AND IN THE
SWEET 16 THAT BULLET IN THERE.
OH GOSH, BUT NO I LIKE THE
WAY YOU THINK I THOUGHT WHY
DID I THINK THAT WE WOULD WE
WOULD PLAY SYRACUSE IN THE
ELITE EIGHT? YES. YES. NO,
THIS IS MUCH. THIS MAKES IT
MUCH MORE INTERESTING
CONVERSATION. LOYAL CHICAGO
VERY UNDER SEATED WOULDN'T
YOU SAY AS AN EIGHT SEED AS
YOU GUYS BUT I WANT TO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THIS
RUN BECAUSE I HAD YOU ON MY
RADIO SHOW EARLIER IN THE
YEAR KIND OF AFTER THAT THAT
THAT BEATDOWN YOU GUYS HAD
IN OREGON STATE AND HOW YOU
HAD A COME TO KIND OF JESUS
MOMENT WITH YOUR TEAM AND THE
DIFFERENCE THAT THAT MADE FOR
THE REST OF THE SEASON AND
WHAT YOU GUYS ULTIMATELY
BECAME TALK ABOUT THAT AND
WHAT THE SEASON WAS LIKE.
YEAH, I MEAN IT WAS TOUGH
EVEN EARLIER IN THE YEAR. WE
LOSE TO PORTLAND AT HOME
AND OVER TIME. I THINK I
THINK THEY ONLY ONE MAYBE SIX
OR SEVEN GAMES WAS WAS A
TOUGH LOSS. YOU KNOW, WE GET
INTO CONFERENCE PLAY RIGHT
AFTER CHRISTMAS. WE HAVE TO
HAVE A PAUSE FOR COVID COUPLE
GUYS TEST POSITIVE AND SO WE
HAD AN EIGHT-DAY PAUSE AND
THEN WE HAD TWO PRACTICES TO
PREPARE FOR, ARIZONA.
AND WE WERE THEIR ONLY GAME
OF THE WEEK BECAUSE OREGON
WAS IN APOSTLE. WE GOT BOTH,
AND ARIZONA STATE WHERE WE
WERE THEIR ONLY GAME OF THE
WEEK AND THEY YEAH, THEY GAVE
US A WOODSHED JOB AND WE HAD
A COUPLE GUYS HURTING THAT
GAME TOO. BUT WE HAD A
MEETING THE NEXT DAY THE
STAFF SEVEN STRAIGHT HOURS.
WE ORDERED IN SOME LUNCH AND
WE JUST GET A SCRUB OF THE
WHOLE DEAL AND WE CAME UP
WITH THIS THAT OUR GUYS WERE
TRYING TO WIN A NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP IN DECEMBER AND
JANUARY AND WE WERE
LISTEN A LOT OF STEPS. SO WE
SAID LET'S LET'S JUST GIVE
THEM THREE THINGS TO FOCUS ON
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO JUDGE
THOSE WHETHER IT WAS A
SUCCESS OR NOT, AND IT WAS
EXECUTING OUR STUFF PRETTY
GENERIC. I KNOW PLAYING
HARDER THAN OUR OPPONENT AND
ENJOYING PLAYING WITH EACH
OTHER THAT WAS MISSING. YOU
KNOW, WE GOT A LOT OF YOUNG
GUYS. WE'VE ONLY GOT A COUPLE
OF EXPERIENCE GUYS, SO WE
SOLD THAT TO THE TEAM. SO
GUYS IF YOU FOCUS ON JUST
THOSE THINGS, IT'LL BE A
SUCCESSFUL GAME IF YOU
IT'LL BE A SUCCESSFUL GAME IF
YOU ACHIEVE THAT AND THEN
IT'LL LEAD TO WINS. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WHEN WE CAN'T
PROMISE YOU BUT THEY BOUGHT
INTO IT. WE WENT ON A THREE
GAME WIN STREAK OUT.
FOR THAT AND GOT THE MOMENTUM
GOING AND THEN ONE OTHER
TURNING POINT AT CAL OUR LAST
ROAD WEEKEND OF THE REGULAR
SEASON. WE'RE YOU KNOW BIG
WEEKEND PLAYING CAL STANFORD.
WE HAVE SOME GUYS KIND OF
ROLL THEIR EYES WHEN THEY
WERE SUBBED OUT ROLL THEIR
EYES WHEN I GOT AFTER HIM FOR
TAKING CRAPPY SHOTS, AND WE
JUST WE LIT THEM UP. WE LIT
THEM UP IN SEVERAL TIMEOUTS.
WE LIT HIM UP AT HALF-TIME. I
MEAN THE PAINT WAS FAILING IN
THE LOCKER ROOM AND OUR GUYS
AND WE EAT GOT A TOUGH WIN
THERE AND THEN WENT TO
STANFORD AND THEY WERE A
LITTLE BEAT UP WITH INJURIES,
BUT A BIG WIN THERE AND
WITH INJURIES BUT A BIG WIN
THERE AND THAT'S WHEN
EVERYTHING KIND OF FELL INTO
PLACE AND THE GUYS WERE LIKE,
OKAY NOW WE'VE HAD ALL THIS
EXPERIENCE. WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT. WE GOT
TO PLAY HARD EVERY DAY PLAY
TOGETHER, YOU KNOW AND STAY
FOCUSED AND NOT WERE NOW
WE'RE IN A SWEET 16 BABY SO I
COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OF THE
GROUP. WE'RE TALKING TO HEAD
COACH OF THE OREGON STATE
UNIVERSITY BEAVERS MEN'S
BASKETBALL.
FOOTBALL COACH WAYNE TINKLE
THE LOST OREGON TO FINISH
THE SEASON HEADING INTO THE
TOURNAMENT IN VEGAS AND THEN
THE LACKLUSTER KIND OF FIRST
HALF WHAT WHAT FLIPPED THE
SWITCH THERE IN VEGAS THAT
TOOK YOU ON THIS RUN THAT
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW,
I THINK IT WAS MORE OF THE
SAME LIKE THEY LIKE THE GUYS
THEY DIDN'T WE DIDN'T FOLLOW
THE SCOUTING REPORT IN THE
GAME AT HOME AGAINST OREGON.
WE LET THEM SHOOT LIGHTS OUT.
THEY GOT IT GOING ON.
YOU KNOW, THEY MADE ELEVEN
MORE THREES THAN US. AND AND
WHAT WE TOLD THE GUYS SHOOT
WE SHOULD HAVE LOST BY 25,
BUT YOU GUYS DID A FEW GOOD
THINGS TO YOU KNOW, KEEP IT,
YOU KNOW SOMEWHAT CLOSE. I
THINK WE LOST BY 11 AND THEN
WE KIND OF CARRIED THAT INTO
THE FIRST GAME AGAINST UCLA.
WE JUST REVERTED BACK TO
INDIVIDUAL PLAY NOT NOT THE
SAME INTENSITY ON THE
DEFENSIVE END AND IN A TIMEOUT
TOWARDS THE END OF THE FIRST
HALF WE SAID,
NO, NO, NO. NO, I DIDN'T
QUITE SAY IT LIKE THAT, BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING BACK TO THE
PAST. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
REMEMBER WHAT HAS, YOU KNOW
BROUGHT SUCCESS AND GET BACK
ON PAGE AND THEN AT HALFTIME,
YOU KNOW SOME ADJUSTMENTS AND
THEN THE GUYS CAME OUT AND
TOTALLY TURN THAT GAME AROUND.
I THINK WE WERE DOWN AS MUCH
AS 16 CAME BACK AND WON THAT
WON IN OVERTIME AND I THOUGHT
THAT WAS KIND OF THAT FINAL
INJECTION OF ENTHUSIASM AND
CONFIDENCE THAT WE NEEDED,
YOU KNOW TO
FORWARD AND YOU KNOW, WE WE
PUT IT ON OREGON PRETTY GOOD
IN THE IN THE SEMIFINALS AND
THEN, YOU KNOW GOT UP AGAINST
COLORADO. THEY MADE A LATE
RUN, BUT WE CLOSED IT OUT AND
YOU KNOW, THEN OUR GUYS HAVE
REALLY BEEN DIALED HERE. I
MEAN YOU SAID IT WE HANDLED
TENANCY AND THEN GOT UP AFTER.
STATE GOT UP 9 FOR WE JUMPED
UP AND GOT A NICE LEAD AND
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE THEY'RE
ATHLETIC IS ALL GET OUT AND
THEN IN TURN THIS OVER A
BUNCH TO GET BACK IN BUT THEN
WE CLOSE THE DOOR ON THEM
LIKE TO SEW
GUYS ARE RIDING QUITE A WAVE.
YEAH, THEY ARE. IT'S BEEN
IT'S BEEN FUN TO WHY IT'S
BEEN FUN TO WATCH THE PAC-12
HAVE SUCCESS AND I WANT MAYBE
YOU TO COMMENT A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE UNDERVALUED
PAC-12 CONFERENCE BECAUSE
GUESS WHAT 25% OF THIS WEEK 16
EVERYBODY 25% YEAH PACK
TWELVE TEAMS, OREGON OREGON
STATE USC AND UCLA,
UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE GOING
TO USC ARE GOING TO BE GOING
UP AGAINST EACH OTHER TO GET
INTO THE ELITE 8, BUT JUST
TALK.
AT THE CONFERENCE IN GENERAL
AND HOW COMPETITIVE IT WAS
THIS YEAR IN THE FACT THAT
YOU HAD TO PLAY MOSTLY
CONFERENCE OPPONENTS IN EVERY
CONFERENCE THIS YEAR. WE
REALLY DIDN'T PROBABLY KNOW
THE REAL VALUE OF EACH AND
EVERY CONFERENCE KNOW FOR
SURE. YEAH. WE DIDN'T HAVE
THOSE CROSS CONFERENCE
PRESEASON GAMES, BUT YOU KNOW
I SAID PEOPLE WERE KIND OF
AMAZED AT HOW WE PERFORM
AGAINST, YOU KNOW, TENNESSEE
AND OKLAHOMA STATE, BUT MY
COMMENT WAS OUR CONFERENCE
PREPARED US FOR THAT. YOU
KNOW, WE WHEN WE GOT
TEAMS THAT CAN DEFEND AND CAN
SCORE. YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S
LIKE SEVEN OUT OF THE LAST
TEN YEARS. WE HAD MORE
PLAYERS IN THE NBA DRAFT THAN
ANY OTHER CONFERENCE. YOU
KNOW, WE'VE GOT SOME GUYS
THAT CAN PLAY, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S GREAT COACHES IN THE
LEAGUE, YOU KNOW, AND IT JUST
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE STATS
NOW, I THINK THIS IS ONLY THE
SECOND TIME THAT A CONFERENCE
HAS HAD TWO TEAMS THAT WERE
DOUBLE DIGIT SEEDS GOING INTO
THE NCAA TOURNAMENT MAKE THE
SWEET SIXTEEN AND I THINK
THE OTHER WHAT WAS THE OTHER
TIME AND SO, YOU KNOW UCLA IN
OURSELVES. I'VE DONE THAT YOU
LOOK AT WHERE 9 AND 1/2 THIS
POINT, YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE
TOURNAMENT. THAT'S ONE OF THE
TOP FIVE BEST STARTS, YOU
KNOW, FOUR TEAMS THAT HAVE AT
LEAST FIVE TEAMS IN THE
TOURNAMENT. SO WE'VE GOT SOME
GUYS THAT CAN PLAY THERE'S
GREAT COACHES. I JUST THINK
YOU KNOW THAT BIASED MOST OF
THE EAST COAST IS ASLEEP WHEN
WE'RE PLAYING OUR GAMES AND
IT'S UNFORTUNATE, BUT
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE A
LITTLE BIT
OF A WAKE-UP CALL FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. ALL
RIGHTY, YOU KNOW I WAS
GONNA WAIT THIS TO MAYBE AT
THE END OF IT, BUT WE'RE
SPEAKING WITH WAYNE TINKLE
HEAD BASKETBALL COACH MEN'S
BASKETBALL COACH AT OREGON
STATE UNIVERSITY. BUT THE
REASON WHY I I TALKED ABOUT
SYRACUSE IS BECAUSE I ALREADY
HAVE YOU EATING LOYOLA
CHICAGO. I KNOW YOU CAN'T
LOOK THAT WAY, BUT I'M JUST
I'M LETTING YOU KNOW, THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE LION WE
THINK. YEAH, I WOULD LOVE
I'VE BEEN I'VE BEEN PUMPING I
SAID, I WANT A ALL PAC-12
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP I WANT,
OREGON.
UCLA USC VERSUS THE OREGON
STATE BEAVERS, I THINK THAT
WOULD BE PERFECT NOT ONLY FOR
ME, BUT I ESPECIALLY THINK
BILL WALTON WOULD ULTIMATELY
RETIRE AND JUST GO TO HEAVEN
IF THAT WERE TO BE THE CASE.
SO YOU'RE RIGHT THERE. I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT LITTLE
KNOWN FACT, RIGHT WAYNE
TINKLE PLAYED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MONTANA COACHED
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF MONTANA
AND WAS AROUND KIND OF AT THE
END OF MY HIGH SCHOOL CAREER,
I'VE ASKED HIM I ASKED HIM
THIS QUESTION BEFORE BUT AND
IT'S IT'S ILLUMINATING. WHAT
WAS THE YOU REMEMBER THE
SCOUTING REPORT ON ME COMING
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AS A
BASKETBALL PLAYER? YES. YEAH
GUY THAT WAS WAS TOUGH ON THE
GLASS HAD PRETTY GOOD TOUCH
COULD STRETCH IT OUT A LITTLE
BIT. MAYBE NOT QUITE TO THE
THREE-POINT LINE, BUT VERY
VERY VERY HIGH SKILL SET AND
COMPETITIVE. I REMEMBER THAT
NOT GOOD NOT GREAT ON
DEFENSE. SO I THINK I'M NOT
GREAT ON.
DEFENSE I THINK WAS PROBABLY
THE OTHER ONE YOU NOTICE. I
ONLY MENTIONED THE OFFENSE.
YES, BUT THE ONE THAT THAT
THAT ENDED UP MAKING WAVES
WAS MY LITTLE BROTHER HE
WOULD GO ON AND GO DOWN AND
PLAY FOR COACH FISHER AT SAN
DIEGO STATE AND HE DIDN'T END
UP PLAYING HIS ENTIRE CAREER
THERE, BUT HE ENDED UP
ACTUALLY BEING THE THE
BASKETBALL PLAYER IN THE
FAMILY. AND THAT WAS THE GUY
THAT WAS THE GUY YOU YOU
REMEMBER TELLING ME THAT
MAYBE WE MAYBE WE DIDN'T TAKE
A STRONG. LOOK AT THAT
YOUNGER LEAF KID.
YEAH, NO EXACTLY AND THEN AND
I CAN'T TAKE THE BLAME. I
DON'T THINK YOU KNOW, I WAS
THE HEAD COACH AT THE TIME
AND I'M TRYING TO PUSH THE
HEAD COACH TO RECRUIT RECRUIT
THEM. I TOLD YOU I REMEMBER
SEEING HIM PLAYING THE THREE
ON THREE TOURNAMENT UP IN
GREAT FALLS AT THE
UP IN GREAT FALLS AT THE
FAIRGROUNDS. YEAH. IT SAID
MAN. WE GOT IT. WE GOT TO GET
ON THIS KID, BUT YOU KNOW,
IT'S YOU'D LIKE TO SEE THOSE
THOSE STORIES OF GUYS FROM
STATES LIKE MONTANA THAT YOU
KNOW, MAYBE THEY DON'T GET
THE RECOGNITION ON THE
NATIONAL SCENE RECRUITING
WISE, BUT THEN YOU GET OUT
AND GO TO GO TO ANOTHER
PROGRAM OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
THAT'S GOOD STUFF. WELL, IT'S
BEEN
SEEING THE SUCCESS. TELL US
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE PLAYERS THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GETTING A
FIRST LOOK AT. I HADN'T HEARD
TOO MUCH ABOUT SILVA IN THE
WAY. HE'S COME AROUND LATE.
YEAH IN THE YEAR A LETICIA.
I KNOW YOU'RE HOPING THAT
HE'S HE CONTINUES WITH HIS
HIGH QUALITY OF PLAY. BUT YOU
KNOW NBA SCOUTS ARE GOING TO
START BE LIKE A BOY THAT THE
LENGTH ON THAT GUY. THIS IS A
TEAM YOU COULD HAVE BACK NEXT
YEAR THAT'S GOING TO BE
PRETTY DARN COMPETITIVE.
NO, WE WE REALLY FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THE RUN WE MADE AND HEY,
I'LL GO BACK TO LAST YEAR.
WE THOUGHT WE WERE POISED FOR
THE SAME KIND OF A RUN. YOU
KNOW, WE HAD ONE SOME LATELY
GAMES. WE WON THAT THAT TOUGH
GAME IN THE TOURNAMENT
AGAINST UTAH WITH THE BUZZER
BEATER, YOU KNOW, AND THEN
THE THING WAS PULLED PULLED
FROM US, BUT YOU KNOW, WE
STRUGGLED EARLY THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OF ALL THE NEW PIECES
AND NOW YOU JUST MENTIONED
TWO HUGE PARTS NOW, YOU KNOW,
ROMAN SILVA, YOU KNOW SPOTTY
PLAYING TIME.
YOU'RE EARLY THIS YEAR. HE'S
GOTTEN HIMSELF INTO ROOT, YOU
KNOW MUCH BETTER SHAPE AND
CONDITION, YOU KNOW, HE
BATTLED THROUGH A COVID PAUSE
AND HE YOU KNOW WORK IS THE
WORK THAT COACH RUPP AND THE
OTHER COACHES HAVE DONE WITH
HIM. WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
THE FRUITS OF THEIR LABOR AND
YOU DON'T WORRY YOU WERE EACH
AN INCREDIBLE REBOUNDER. HE'S
SO WRONG. HE'S ONLY BEEN
PLAYING FOR A HANDFUL OF
YEARS. HE NEEDS SOME TIME.
THAT'S WHAT WE KEEP TELLING
THE SCOUT SAKE. DON'T DON'T
DON'T GO AFTER HIM NOW. HE
NEEDS A LITTLE MORE. I'LL
IT MARINATING BUT
YOU LOOK AT THOSE TWO GUYS
COMING BACK SOME OF THOSE
OTHER YOUNGER GUYS, YOU KNOW,
JIONNI HUNT JARED LUCAS TARIQ
SILVER, YOU KNOW WHO HASN'T
PLAYED MUCH IT ACTUALLY
TWEAKED HIS ANKLE LAST WEEK
TO HUGE BUCKETS FOR US IN THE
SECOND HALF AGAINST OKLAHOMA
STATE BECAUSE WE WERE RIDDLED
FOUL TROUBLE YOU ETHAN
THOMPSON AND JARED LUKE HAS A
CRY: A LETICIA ON THE BENCH.
SO WE THOUGHT THIS THE DEPTH
ON THIS TEAM WOULD BE OUR
STRENGTH. WE JUST NEEDED FOR
IT TO GET TO WHERE THEY WERE
CONFIDENT COULD START
PRODUCING.
ASSISTANT LEE AND WE FEEL
WHERE THEY'RE SO IN THE
RECRUITS WE HAVE TIME FOR
NEXT YEAR. WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON,
AND YOU KNOW, WE'VE STILL
WANT TO MAKE THIS CONTINUE
THIS RUN OBVIOUSLY THIS
WEEKEND, BUT THE FUTURE LOOKS
WE'RE TALKING DO HEAD COACH
OF THE OREGON STATE MEN'S
BASKETBALL TEAM WAYNE TINKLE
RIGHT NOW IN THE SWEET 16.
WE'LL TAKE ON LOYOLA CHICAGO
BIT OF A TOURNAMENT DARLING
AS WELL. HOW WE GET YOU OUT
OF HERE ON THIS UNPRECEDENTED
UNCONVENTIONAL YEAR IN A
BUBBLE IN THE INDIANAPOLIS
AREA, YOU KNOW PLAYERS NOT
REALLY BEING ABLE TO SPEND
TIME WITH ONE ANOTHER OTHER
THAN ON THE PRACTICE COURT.
UM, HOW ARE YOU KEEPING THEM
LOOSE? HOW IS EVERYBODY
STAYING MOTIVATED AND READY
FOR THE NEXT NEXT MATCHUP?
YEAH, THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
BECAUSE THAT'S THE CHALLENGE.
I MEAN, WE'RE ON DAY 16 ON THE
ROAD WHEN YOU LOOK AT VEGAS
AND HERE BOTH BUBBLE
SITUATIONS, YOU KNOW, REALLY
THE ONLY FREE TIME WE HAVE
THERE'S A THERE'S LIKE A
DOUBLE AA OR AAA BASEBALL
PARK ACROSS THE STREET AND WE
GET AN HOUR A DAY TO GO WALK.
AROUND THEY HAVE SOME
FOOTBALLS OUT THERE. WE PUT
UP SOME PRETTY COOL VIDEOS
GUYS PLAYING FOOTBALL
PICKLEBALL AND THEN BOOM IT'S
BACK TO YOUR ROOM. SO, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE STAYING IN TOUCH
WITH THEM CONSTANTLY MAKING
SURE THEY GOT EVERYTHING THEY
NEED, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW
NOWADAYS. I MEAN THEY'VE ALL
GOT THEIR IPADS AND THEY'RE
JUMPING ON NETFLIX AND
YOUTUBE AND ALL THAT, BUT WE
CERTAINLY HAVE TO STAY
FOCUSED TO YOU KNOW, THEIR
MENTAL STATE BECAUSE THIS IS
YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU SAID IT'S
UNPRECEDENTED AND SO WE'RE
CONSTANTLY
IN COMMUNICATION THIS
AFTERNOON THEY GET TO SNEAK
OUT TO TOP GOLF SO ACTUALLY
GET OUT IN A WAY FROM THE
HOTEL WHICH WILL BE NICE FOR
THEM. THE COACHING STAFF WILL
BE AND WILL BE
TEAM ROOM BREAKING DOWN VIDEO,
BUT THAT'LL BE NICE FORM.
AND SO WE'RE JUST, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP THEM
LOOSE ON THE PRACTICE COURT,
BUT YET KEEPING THEM FOCUSED
AND INTENSE AT THE SAME TIME.
JUST TELL THEM TO ENJOY THE
RIDE WHY CHANGE NOW, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENT. WE SAID
THIS GOING INTO THE
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME IN VEGAS
DON'T DO ANYTHING DIFFERENT
BECAUSE THIS IS, YOU KNOW
MEANS WE CAN GO TO THE NCAA
TOURNAMENT. JUST DO WHAT WE
DO SAID THE SAME THING AFTER
THE TENNESSEE GAME WILL SAY
THE SAME THING THIS WEEKEND,
I SURE HOPE SO, IT'S
IN A PLEASURE, LIKE I SAID
COVERING YOU GUYS THIS YEAR
AND WATCHING IT TAKE PLACE ON
THE NATIONAL STAGE. SO KEEP
AT IT BEST OF LUCK AGAINST
LOYAL TO CHICAGO. I ALREADY
KNOW WHERE THAT'S GOING. WISH
BOYS THE BEST OF LUCK AND
WE'LL HOPEFULLY MAYBE HAVE
YOU ON THE SHOW NEXT WEEK.
YEAH. SOUNDS GOOD. I
APPRECIATE YOU REACHING OUT.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TALKING TO
YOU CAN'T SAY ENOUGH. HOW
PROUD I AM OF OUR GUYS MAN
FOR ALL THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH
AND ALL THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENT.
IT'S A PRETTY SPECIAL GROUP.
THEY SIT DOWN AND GO BEAVS GO
BEAVS HEAD